what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to another one of these
reaction videos today we're going to be
taking a look at halo infinite
the official gameplay revealed trailer
this is going to be super interesting
for me to look at
because it's going to be the first real
xbox new xbox game that we'll be taking
a look at last time i did flight
simulator i thought
that flight simulator was running on an
xbox because it had the xbox logo on
like the first
few frames of the trailer but turns out
it's just it's just called xbox game
studios that's just all of microsoft's
games in our xbox game studios and of
course it was running on a pc which
is obvious in retrospect this however is
running on an xbox and so i'm really
excited to see
what games running on the next
generation xbox actually are going to
look like now
interestingly there is actually like an
eight minute nine minute gameplay demo
so we're gonna start off with just
looking at that i don't know how
interested
you guys are in this if you want me to
check out the full nine minute like
gameplay
leave a comment below but for starters
we're just gonna start off light you
know we're going to start off easy we'll
just
take a look at this minute trailer see
what we can get from it the way that i
look at this as well is that this is a
reveal trailer this is a gameplay reveal
trailer it's one minute
you know this is supposed to be the most
impressive stuff if a game studio is
going to be making a trailer for a game
they should probably show the best
things in the trailer right to get
players excited so i'm assuming
everything here is going to be super
polished
and i expect it might even look better
than the gameplay even though i have not
seen
either let's get right into this and
take a look at what
the xbox is going to look like using my
old headphones today because the other
ones just don't seem to be working right
now
humans call you their savior
die well
now i'm not much of a halo player i mean
i remember playing like
halo trial on pc on like laptops in high
school like we'd set up like a lan party
we played blood gulch that was
amazing then i played a little bit of
halo reach a little bit of
halo 4 when i got like an xbox 360.
that for the most part that was it but
this
this looks like a current gen game i'm
going to have to watch this again and
see if i can actually spot an extra
i i was not trying to look at this
trailer like
a game engine like developer trying to
like you know
analyze every frame i was just trying to
watch it for how i would just see it as
a normal person first before i started
analyzing it
but to me this does not feel next gen at
all
let's let's maybe let's try and analyze
it a bit more and
maybe we'll see the next gen details
i mean don't get me wrong it definitely
doesn't look bad but obviously this is
like you know to me this is like oh the
big reveal of the new xbox like
okay this admittedly is kind of cool
um you know if he's like dynamically
swiping away all this frost like you
know the
the general like quality of this frame
does not look bad by any means
this guy he's he's got some nice
lighting on him there's
a fair amount of detail but like maybe
that's just the aesthetic but looking at
his teeth
and stuff like this they look like
plastic like i
look at like the i don't know i'm just
not
just not impressed by him
this general fog that they're using to
fade out
the map starts so quickly and again
like you know i don't know like the the
the problem with this is that everything
here could be done
for aesthetical reasons like it could be
done because that's the art style
it could be done because well the map is
foggy there's no way to kind of you know
it's really difficult to go in this with
a critical eye and start just you know
saying this is bad that's bad because
maybe maybe the point is it's supposed
to be like this but
this fade out seems to start at like 10
meters and
i mean by the time you get over here
this just this is just like a silhouette
and look at those kind of like i don't
know i don't know what that's supposed
to be but
to me it looks like a very low
resolution texture on that from this far
away which isn't even that far away
those trees in the distance look pretty
bad this whole fog situation here this
place like
some of this looks like halo 3 to me
like
this looking at this frame
regardless of what i say next in this
video
looking at this frame this looks like a
current gen game
in fact that's being generous
okay once we start like coming out with
the effects and we get closer we can see
the reflections
you know i'm going to go frame by frame
here you know those reflections look
um just waiting for them to be dynamic
here
yeah can i see the reflection of the
particles on him i can't tell at the
moment this just looks like i don't know
what that's reflecting it looks like
some yellow light is clearly blue
i mean here's blue which might make that
hard but i don't i
did not see a single kind of reflection
on that
whatsoever so far at least there we go
that's just faded out
okay these these textures don't look too
bad but the problem is to me they look
like textures they don't look like
like it's very difficult like to me that
looks like just a
texture with like a normal map i'm not
sure if there's any displacement going
on here i'm not sure if
if i'm not sure what the poly count is
here or like how much tessellation is
happening it looks
it looks fairly it looks fairly
primitive to me as does this little
patch of grass here the depth of field
is nice i guess i like the out of focus
lights they look pretty cool admittedly
the charac the animation looks looks
nice
his hair looks pretty good let's see if
we can spot any more
details here and
just like a quick disclaimer like again
maybe the gameplay is going to show a
lot more because this did not show much
to me this was a very
this trailer passed like that um i
didn't really
get a chance to um you know think about
it much
but again you know i would expect this
to show the best stuff right
or at least one would expect this to
show the best stuff
um okay we've got some grunts over there
ah those little sticky things i remember
those forgot what they're called
okay look he's got some lighting on him
do you see what the problem is though
the problem is that i'm trying my best
to find things that look good here but
my human brain when it looks at this
does not think it looks particularly
good
you know if i have to search for the
next gen features and the next
gen technology in this game i feel like
i feel like that's disappointing
that looks pretty good but it's like
it's not like you can interact with that
like could be anything could be a matte
painting like just a
texture
okay here we go i'm assuming these are
ray trace lights finally
they look pretty good even though they
almost look like specular highlights
i like i like how they distort with with
the roughness of his like visor and
like the general texture of his suit
that looks cool there we go we had some
light here i mean that's just normal
light i guess
just a point light or something
just trying to go back here so i can see
the particle effect here
so what do we have here so we have this
thing landing
it hits this thing it immediately snaps
to the damage model
and then the door flies away with some
sparks
all pretty standard there's some extra
particle systems and i went near as much
as ratchet and clank though
which again is is irrelevant but just
something i
i noticed whoa did those just disappear
instantly
look at that man one frame they're here
and they're being like you know they're
being animated
next frame they're gone
look all of these particles just
disappear
they didn't even let me enjoy that
explosion as soon as it happened it cut
away why is it going to disappear in the
next frame as well
look lots of debris lots of particles
and then
here we go he's getting blown back and
then become the hope
look at that background
i think the ground there was being
illuminated a little bit
by his light
no this is no
i'm sorry i don't like this
i don't like this at all i think that it
looks
i think that it looks fairly average for
a current gen game
i don't know exactly what uh
went wrong i don't know if it's just
the team or the art direction or if it's
the hardware
i have no idea like
i i can't say anything other than i just
did not enjoy that i did not enjoy that
maybe the gameplay the eight minute nine
minute whatever gameplay
trailer is better if it is let me know
but what did you guys think i feel kind
of bad because i haven't really
reacted to anything and then said well
what what appears to be so much negative
stuff but
but like am i is this just me is this is
this
does this look really good i know some i
i read like one like one person tweeted
at me
saying that it wasn't like it didn't
look great but like
what's the general consensus here i'm
gonna might read some of these comments
actually
okay people are just kind of talking
about people are just talking about the
actual game that's cool they're not
talking about the graphics or anything
okay someone's saying the overall art
design looks generic
anyway i hope you enjoyed my reaction
more than i did because i don't think i
did
if you did then maybe hit the like
button below or don't because
i am really interested to see what you
guys thought so definitely leave a
comment below
with your thoughts about this maybe
there are some
good points that you'll bring up that i
can make a follow-up video to and
discuss a little bit more maybe while
watching
the rest of the gameplay um but
yeah if there's anything else you want
me to take a look at if there's there's
some other
new xbox game trailer that maybe
actually
shows more of the power of the console
or something like that then let me know
but otherwise i guess i'll see you guys
later
man this feels weird goodbye
you